hey guys it's Jonah here I'm feeling
really good because I just filled my
fridge up with lots of fresh nutritious
food I really do enjoy my weekly food
shopping because it gets me excited over
preparing delicious home-cooked meals so
be sure to give this video a thumb up if
you feel the same as well what you saw
at home has a huge influence over your
eating habits so if you're looking to
lead a healthy lifestyle your food
contributes eighty percent to your
success hence picking the right food is
crucial in maintaining a healthy weight
if you do not know where to start or if
you would like to learn more about
healthy eating do watch my 7 must have a
grocery list video for a basic food
shopping guide I started learning more
about healthy eating when I started my
fitness journey about six years ago it
has changed my relationship towards food
and the choices I make for my body so if
you guys are interested about fitness
healthy living or to help others to get
healthy the National Academy of Sports
Medicine & ASM is a great platform to
start I did my women's fitness
specialist course with them and they are
currently offering a 14-day free trial
for the online personal training costs
so if you're interested link and more
information is in my description box so
before you do your grocery shopping it
is very important for you to roughly
plan out your meals for the week and you
must have a grocery list with you if you
go without knowing what you want chances
are you might end up with more junk than
wholesome food so let's see what's on my
grocery list so I like to write my
grocery list according to the different
sections in the supermarket for instance
I have categorized it into meat or chill
section vegetables can or drive food
section fruits and snacks this helps me
to move around the supermarket more
efficiently especially when I'm tied on
time so I like to start with vegetables
as that the longest on my list I'll
start with my usual favorite vegetable
karates I like to pick my own carrots
and I prefer smaller carrots because it
is easier for me to snack on the entire
carrot here's something you might not
know I've been eating carrots almost on
a daily basis ever since I was young and
I have to say it's the secret behind my
good vision so if you want good vision
snack on carrots next let us and also
cherry tomatoes these are my favorite
vegetables because they don't need any
preparation and it makes it very easy
for me to prep a quick salad I
definitely must have in every fridge so
if they're not on your grocery list be
sure to add them in so let's move on and
buy ingredients to make my favorite
cucumber mint color drink so that's one
whole cucumber you know sometimes when I
wake up with puffy eyes I like to place
sliced cucumbers on my eyes it really
helps to reduce puffiness and also make
me feel more awake I will also need some
fresh mint leaves and also line to make
the natural flavored water let's also
get some lemons to make lemon water in
the morning and I also like to add lemon
in my cooking I'm actually thinking of
making my favorite Malaysian crispy
seaweed spring rolls sometime this week
I might even share this recipe with you
for that I'll need yin bean or more
commonly known as sink Wong in Malaysia
hmm I'm also planning to stir-fries some
cabbage and long beans when I have my
mum over this week it's her favorite
and of course spring onions to enhance
the flavors and just because the proko
spinach looks so fresh I'm going to get
some and make herbal soup as well so
just remember to be somewhat flexible
with your food shopping and choose
seasonal vegetables which are fresh I
also have potatoes planned at this week
so let's grab a small packet so while
walking through the chilled section
looking for tofu I noticed that my
favorite mushroom is currently on
half-price promotion it's not on my list
but
it's a really good deal so I'm adding
this into my cooking if you're on a
budget an important tip is to be
flexible and choose food which are
currently on promotion it helps you to
experiment with different recipes and
even save money one thing I really like
about being in Malaysia is that we get a
huge selection of fresh tofu and they're
so cheap as well my favorite is silken
tofu and choose the one with no added
preservatives another awesome thing
about living here is that I get to enjoy
fresh coconut yup not bottled coconut
drink which to be honest tastes funny
and is definitely way over hyped as a
health drink hands over price here it is
something we drink very often I like to
also buy Greek yogurt to add into my
cooking use it as a healthier
alternative for salad dressing or dips
and also mix it with fruits so choose
plain yogurt rather than flavored yogurt
as they tend to be higher in sugar now
that I got all my vegetables that mix up
the largest part on my list let's head
over to the meat section so when I cook
at home I like to mostly use chicken
breasts or fish they are my preferred
source of protein lower in fat and
easier to cook I'm thinking of having
steamed tilapia with the family this
week growing up we would have fish for
dinner every single day without fail
even now when I'm back visiting my
parents that will still be fish for
dinner my dad loves fish and over the
weekends I like to make smoked salmon
with poached eggs I probably eat this a
little too often so let's also grab a
tray of eggs if possible choose
free-range organic eggs especially if
the price difference isn't huge I'll
then head to the canned food section and
buy tuna cans with a huge selection of
different brands and even flavors it is
very important to read the food label
and ingredients list I prefer the tuna
chunks in mineral water as it is much
lower in salt and tastes better
so I tend to stock up on tuna cans as
when I'm back feeling tired and not
wanting to cook I can simply have tuna
with bread or make tuna salad so it is
also very important to buy healthy
convenient food
let's also grab a can of containers to
add into my cooking or salad of course
the fresh corn will be a better option
but you know what sometimes I do like
things a little more convenient
just remember to choose corn which are
not sweetened next bread for my morning
breakfast
of course bread from the bakery tends to
smell and taste so much better I'm still
discovering my neighborhood and haven't
found a favorite bakery just yet
for now I'll settle with the 100% whole
grain bread it is thin but very filling
and tastes good and not forgetting
papaya or spring roll wraps to make the
crispy seaweed spring rolls right I'm
done I'm gonna pay and head out all of
that costs just slightly over 100
Ringgit which is less than $30 not a bad
Buy to get my fruits I have a favorite
fruit stall which I tend to visit I
don't really have a fruit list I prefer
to see the selection of fresh fruits
they have what's in season and decide
what to buy
look at those dragon fruits so big and
definitely look like it's going to taste
sweet so let's grab them and also
mangoes of course some bananas which I
like to eat on the go add into smoothies
or even on toasts I like to buy my
fruits in small quantity to make sure
that I get to eat them fresh
so I'll visit this place twice a week
finally to get my nuts and dried fruits
there's this small stall in a shopping
center which I go to they sell a huge
selection of high-quality nuts seeds and
dried fruits at a very reasonable price
and not forgetting the endless sampling
that this really nice lady would offer
me every time I visit so this time I've
decided to go for a packet of pistachio
nuts and dried apricots
food shopping done so guys that's pretty
much my weekly grocery shopping of
course every week will be slightly
different depending on what I want to
eat need to replenish or what's
currently in season at the moment I
still have lots of basic cooking
ingredients such as onion garlic rice
couscous oatmeal peanut butter herbs and
spices which I don't need so let me know
what's in your grocery list in the
comments below
and if you find this video to be helpful
be sure to like it and share it as well
all the best
you